part of your parenting the kids do not
wear diapers oh no so my kids did not
wear diapers that's called elimination
communication but it's actually I know
I know from attachment parenting many
men do attachment parenting do this but
yeah so you basically babies are born
giving signals when they pee and poop I
promise and if you learn those signals
and reinforce them they will give them
stronger and clearer and we taught our
kids to sign this is the Sign Language
sign for potty by the time they were 12
months old they were signing for potty
they couldn't walk talk or eat solids
they only breastfed but they could sign
for the potty before they could even
walk talk is it the same Theory with a
dog like dogs will teach you can teach
them to go to the bathroom outside right
so you're more training yourself to
learn the cues that the baby will give
and if you don't reinforce them a baby
will stop giving those cues and it's not
for everyone believe me but yeah
especially with boys it's easy we just
hold them up over a tree